(man)
Let's see your stuff, man.
Oh!
Yeah!
[applause]
Yeah! See?
- Thank you.
- That's great.
Oh! Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
Don't fall in the street.
Oh! Man!
Damn.
[chuckles]
I like it.
[laughing]
Damn, you're good!
Is this guy
just now realizing
black people are amazing
at stuff?
That's Rico, and he's so good
at his job, he sucks at it.
I have no idea which way
Gables River Oaks is.
But when some honky
filmed him,
he became known as the greatest
sign spinner of all time.
Sign spinning is baton twirling
for boys.
It was invented in Kansas
when a guy wearing a sandwich
board got sucked into a tornado.
The day I take my taxes
to a place
because a sign spinner
pointed me there
is the day I go to jail.
Sign spinners are the whores
of the advertising world.
They work on street corners,
they're paid in cash,
and the police don't ask
too many questions
when they turn up dead.
It's a step above Mexicans
snapping a deck of hooker cards
on the Vegas strip
and a step below the big wiggly
balloon guy at used car lots.
Hiring a sign spinner is
a company's way of advertising
that they can't afford
a billboard.
In case you don't live
in a real city,
billboards are the things
that tell you
where the next
Cracker Barrel is.
They're the spam
of the American landscape.
My biggest problem
with sign spinners is,
they put up
one heck of a fight
when you try to spray-paint
a dick on their forehead.
Rico is really, really good
at something
that is really, really dumb.
That's why I flew him to L.A.,
where I've never seen
a sign spinner
because I'm always
too busy texting,
in this week's
Ce-web-rity Profile.
[applause]
Hey, I'm Rico.
- Are you my driver?
- Nope.
I was just told
to point you
in the direction
of the SuperShuttle.
Go that way,
down the third median.
(woman)
Esperanza.
Puerto Rico! Oh!
Be right with you.
Yes, you, okay.
Keep this pointed left
this time.
You got, like, a song
in your head?
(Daniel)
Rico.
Welcome to L.A.
Fresh off the bus, huh?
Actually, I flew here.
Ooh.
Slow down, hotshot.
Everybody wants
to be famous.
(all)
Nobody wants to do the work.
Everybody wants
to be famous.
(all)
Nobody wants to do the work.
I know you're a big shot
in Houston,
but so is Dwight Howard,
so that's meaningless.
This is L.A., city of dreams
and/or angels.
Do you know how many big shots
are sign spinners here?
All right, I got a lot
of questions about spinning.
First of all,
how much money do you make
per hour spinning?
Currently, I make
$15 an hour.
So how did this--this one video
become so popular?
Some dude came up to me.
He was like, "Dude, like,
you're awesome.
Let me--just do your thing,
you know."
(man)
Let's see your stuff, man.
Damn!
He could have been
a predator.
I mean, he looks like somebody
that might want to,
like, take you, like,
to his place,
lock you up
in a basement...
Yeah.
And just come down and watch
you spin signs for him.
I'll use my sign as a weapon,
so it's good.
Do you spin based on the music
you're listening to?
Yeah. Sometimes.
Do you ever, like,
listen to talk radio
while you're spinning?
Like, Bill O'Reilly--
"No Spin Zone."
Who's your favorite
blue-collar comedy star?
Bill Engvall,
"Here's Your Sign."
- No, I--
- That's what he says.
He always goes,
"Here's your sign."
It's not--
he's no one's favorite.
Don't worry about it.
Do you ever get tipped
by people?
Mm-hmm.
One time, somebody gave me,
like, $20 in all change.
I've done that before
to homeless people.
Who are the people
most likely to tip you?
Mostly white women...
with accents.
- Did he tip you?
- No.
This guy basically just
forced you to work for free.
There's a name for that.
What's the name?
[laughs]
What are the weirdest things
people have
said or done to you
while you're working?
One time, I was riding
the sign like a horse.
That's very sexual.
Yeah, someone called in
and said, like, it's a penis.
I was like, "Come on, man.
It's a horse."
I said, "Yee-haw."
They probably didn't hear
the "yee-haw."
Yeah.
They just saw you thrusting
on the sidewalk
with a huge arrow
coming out
between your legs.
I don't know, man.
It's a trick, man.
Yeah, that was
a real good trick.
The pony, man.
[both laughing]
I used to work at Best Buy
as a kid,
and I would spin the CDs
on my finger all day long.
I thought that was so cool.
Then you could be
a professional sign spinner.
But things would have to go
horribly wrong for me.
I mean, you could do it
on the side.
Would you consider yourself the
Michael Jordan of sign spinning?
I consider myself the
Kobe Bryant of sign spinning.
That's a controversial pick,
but okay.
Yeah, it's
'cause I'm in L.A.
Oh, I thought
you were implying
because you are
past your prime
and just sucking
the company dry.
[laughing]
Has anyone ever tried to get you
to get in their car?
Yes.
It was a guy.
What did he want?
The PG version
of what he said is,
"Are you looking
for a good time?"
I was playing blackjack once
in Vegas when I was younger,
and I didn't realize it
until, like,
after I left
that there was a guy there
that thought I was a hooker.
He was flirting with you?
Yes, but I just thought he was
just happy when I was winning.
And, like, he was, like,
patting me on the back...
[both laughing]
But I was kind of flattered
in a weird way.
I was like, "Eh..."
All right, Rico,
I'm gonna go against
my better judgment
and give you a shot.
I'm gonna start you off
with an easy assignment.
(Rico) What do we want?
(all) Yes, we do.
(Rico) When do we want it?
(all) You bet.
(all)
♪ Shame, shame, shame ♪
♪ Shame, shame ♪
Get down! Tear gas!
[all cheer]
All right. Finished.
Good work.
Viacom caved.
Now you're ready
for something important.
Because a little eight-year-old
girl named Casey is missing.
I'll do my best.
[siren wailing]
You did it, Rico.
Thanks to your awesome
sign spinning,
over 5,000 black Teslas
were impounded.
Did they find Casey?
That's not your problem.
But no.
They did find
two dead hookers.
So at least their families
got some closure.
I think you're ready
for the big-time.
I'm gonna give you
the only sign-spinning job
that really matters:
tricking people
into watching me do stand-up.
All right,
let's see your stuff.
Duh-damn!
Y'all see that?
I like it.
Oh!
Don't go in the street.
[energetic dubstep music]
♪ ♪
[in slow-motion]
Damn!
♪ ♪
[in slow-motion]
Oh!
♪ ♪
[gunshots]
I'm getting too dizzy for this.
I quit.
Thank you. Thank you.
Um...
That's the last time I use a
sign spinner to promote a show.
Very urban crowd.
If you pass Rico on the streets,
give him a nice long honk.